today marks the day where we embark on a
new adventure to build another primitive
technology village we're heading out to
SC village again and we'll be out there
for probably two days building the set
we used last time got completely washed
away in a huge flood because it's been
raining so much here in California so
the only thing left standing was the
second Shack that Sam's character was
living at and so we're gonna take that
we're gonna rebuild that entirely we're
gonna add a fireplace we're gonna add a
workbench we're gonna kit it out we're
gonna make it bigger it's only gonna be
Jared and Nick and myself who are gonna
be responsible to build this thing and
we're shooting this video early next
week so we've only got about two days to
get it done
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna redo this Nick and we're
gonna be with us this one we're gonna
move to like right here and
this one
middle yeah and then it's gonna run this
way
let's find some more big big boys huh
George
that's that's the one there yeah that
one's stuck got no branches on it
16 now sir there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hahaha
just right
that's probably why I don't know where
my grandfather's from I told you about
this yeah my mom's dad no idea where
he's from he says he's from he said all
we know is he was from Norway quote yeah
and it spelled his last name Olsen with
an old which is the Norwegian spelling
right but I
did the I did the 23andme and I've got
like the amount that he says he's
Norwegian so that'd be that make me a
quarter yeah on the 23andme test I'm
like half Swedish half no region for
that section right so it's like somehow
not related are although there's all
related yeah like come on my favorite
thing was Conan had his
yeah it was like thrown in here you're
like a hundred percent Irish he's like I
kept those things like no you don't
understand
Irish you have to be inbred
well I guess that's how you look like
this
it's great like it made me go wow I
almost want to like get into baseball
he's good I don't care about sports this
is a carrot I know you don't want kids
but I'd strongly consider it you really
think that because then you become a dad
at baseball will be like
whole new meaning to me huh it's in here
it takes up its every day it's like I
can watch it every day I can watch the
kid at the same time
and then when they're old enough I can
teach them how to play it yeah and if
they're good at it then they can take
care of me yeah it's like the perfect
sport of it and it's not dangerous and
that leaves not like football I like
football
I'm telling them thick yeah all right
dude Village People
yeah that's great
[Music]
hey everyone I wanted to take a moment
away from today's primitive expedition
say thanks to keeps for sponsoring
today's episode it's the easiest and
most convenient way to keep the hair you
have that's why it's called keeps if
you're anything like me and you're a guy
who's getting anywhere near the age of
35 while the chances are you've probably
experienced some form of hair loss and
that can be a little bit difficult to
deal with especially I remember the
first time I looked in the mirror and
thought hey am I losing a little hair
right there keeps can help you keep the
hair you have and it's real simple all
you do is go online and a licensed
physician will look at your information
and give you the prescription that they
think you need keeps us able to keep the
costs low by offering the same generic
versions of fda-approved drugs so for
only 10 to 35 bucks a month you can get
a prescription that's delivered directly
to your door every three months anyway
it's worth looking into I want you guys
to know about it because well quite
frankly I don't know how much I got more
to last up here I don't know so if
you're interested head on over to keeps
calm size toward our crew and you'll get
your first month free now back to that
primitive technology
we made a lot of good progress yesterday
and now we're gonna load up we're gonna
go back down there and we're gonna
finish the camp the hut with the fence
with the fireplace and the workbench I'm
going to work on that log engine
it's like
Bolshevism is easy to understand when
you're pissed off yeah
like these people have kept you down for
a thousand years let's just kill them
all that'll work like great subscribe
button yeah um that'll change everything
we got it it'll change everything not in
the way that you think yeah
got him boys
classic got a moment of history classic
that that's a joke classic bottom of a
Dada moments of history the Bolshevik
Revolution
got him
[Applause]
I hope it doesn't subscribing rain too
much
subscribe destroy all of our work I
think we'll be okay up here it would
really have to rain for there to get
water up here
steers chunga's
dear Chum this please keep the rain away
for another day
rain rain go away
I
picked up the stick and I found an
ancient artifact
[Music]
this this water took down a huge tree
and so I cut the stump and a bunch of
stuff off of it
Oh God we're in Nettles now
subscribe Hey yeah like the Roman
legionaries
by the fireplace and the tall ones
Beauty Sam's chair
oh no
it's gonna be a bench
that's gonna be a fireplace bench yeah
we're like though I was gonna put it
between the fire spit in the work bench
[Music]
[Applause]
it broke his heart this goddamn heart
always did hate rice
yeah
well you would too if that's all you're
handed a PFW camp true goddamn
Philippines
I'd like to see you surviving subscribe
PPO W camp in Vietnam for four years
yeah like have policy problems of John
McCain sure but I respect the damn man
like
cheese and gigs
damn dude look at that she's good yeah
yeah that's a great
we're here to introduce you to our hot
new crib the hottest of the hot the best
of the best check out these days we've
extended the original HUD I don't know
if you remember but this was Sam [ __ ]
check the best is the best part right
here yo Sam's sick lounging throne check
this thing out boom you see this zombie
fence right here this is some of the
best money can buy right here next up is
it a bench well yeah it's a bench but
not for sitting it's a crafting bench
you got a backer so you don't lose your
minerals you got extra hooks for your
tools put your axe right there you can
craft whatever you want of course the
hearth classic Center framed stone bound
fire placing spit with V sticks I mean
this is just as classic as it gets right
here and you know I like some things
unorthodox I like some things fresh but
there's some things you just keep
original and one of those things is in
the heart so I'm really excited about
this all in all this is definitely a
palace so anyway thanks for stopping by
get out of here oh yeah I know you get
out of here hey you get out here you get
you get
[Music]
vodcast I really want to be start being
in more corridor
super movement chopsticks I challenge
you to go a full day using chopsticks as
your hands and you'll put me in the
video yeah four hours hey Nico Oh
Clint's gonna put me in the video and
enjoy it
today is the day where I get to be the
star in the video
all right cool you ready it is to do
what to film the video the chopsticks
video claims chopsticks yeah yeah so
what I need you to do is stand basically
right there and I'm just gonna record a
quick little segment of you I don't know
why I didn't have anything to do with
the video leave are you yeah believe we
are used for yeah are you though
do you know what I had to do for this
you're gonna fill down a green screen
for two seconds yeah that's gonna make a
whole video like I mean I think that's
the idea this doesn't make any money
even a key light that's been the wrong
guy you're asking the wrong guy
okay we
record this
[Music]
[Music]